if you've been listening to the show for
30 seconds or more you probably figured
out Dave Ramsey doesn't like credit
cards why is that well because they're
not a blessing they're curse I know some
of you think you are winning and you're
humorous in your idiocy but you're not
winning and I mean under the heading of
just bizarre stupid stuff is this this
just comes out this week Apple is
warning its customer that some fabrics
such as leather or denim could cause
permanent discoloration to the Apple
card Apple's new titanium which you
would think would be you know fairly
strong credit card comes with a
potential headache that will be familiar
to iPhone users everywhere it can get
scuffed up too easily in the real world
Apple updated its support webpage this
week to warn customers that some fabrics
such as leather and denim could cause
permanent discoloration to the Apple
card the damage won't wash off Apple
also advises against placing the card in
a wallet slot that has already had a
different credit card so that it doesn't
get scratched and the company says
customers should not store their Apple
card in a pocket or bag with loose
change keys or other potentially
abrasive objects in general the apple
cart should not be let out into the wild
it has it's kind of fragile it's
precious
it's a petite flower it scratches easily
and screws up easily but if you remember
now when Apple did their big
announcement what was their big
announcement they put an emphasis in the
launch on the beautiful look of the card
it has no numbers on it it's just a
little white card with a little apple on
it and they're well aware that people
use credit cards because of the way they
look this is how dumb some people are
it's got my football teams logo on it
it's a gold
piece of plastic which makes it superior
to a normal piece of plastic in this
case it's a white piece of titanium that
scratches and diss colors easily but I'm
cool because I've got an Apple card if
you do sign up for the card Apple
recommends putting it in a wallet pocket
or a bag made of soft materials in
general don't take it out of the
envelope that you got it in and don't
use it and then it won't get scratched
that's the general thing they also
suggest carry cleaning the titanium card
by wiping it with a microfiber cloth
moistened with alcohol you now are so
dumb that you have a credit card that
comes with care and feeding instructions
it comes with its own microfiber cloth
and own little pouch of alcohol so that
it maintains its beautiful look which
means that you have maintained your
status as an idiot that took a credit
card based on its beauty oh this is
funny I'm just saying this is funny it's
pitiful but it's funny so the guys in
the Ramsey baby-steps community the
official baby steps community the
official Ramsey baby steps community on
Facebook it's a private Facebook group
but a couple hundred thousand of you are
in there somebody starts this thread up
that ends up being hilarious in there of
course one of you did it it wasn't me I
didn't even do it they just printed it
off for me this morning and my guys
decide this is funny so I'm supposed to
read it but it is funny things that are
more likely to happen than Dave Ramsey
using a credit card fill in the blank
things that are more likely to happen
than Dave Ramsey using a credit card
going shopping at Hobby Lobby and
getting lunch at chick-fil-a on Sunday
there you go Chris Hogan doing a Capital
One commercial ooh the Nigerian prince
transferring all the millions by email
oh this one's brutal the
Buffalo Bills winning the Super Bowl oh
I didn't say it Chuck Norris losing a
fight
a Chuck Norris joke makes it I like it
Anthony O'Neal taking out a student loan
to get his master's degree and
left-handed puppetry from Pepperdine
things that are more likely to happen
than Dave Ramsey using a credit card a
blizzard in Phoenix the government
following and using the Dave Ramsey plan
for California becoming an affordable
state Oh sounds personal hearing a live
from the Ford lease program studios this
is the Dave Ramsey show true that won't
happen the Cleveland Browns on a winning
streak well we got a couple of football
trashes in here things more likely to
happen than Dave Ramsey using a credit
card
Dave opens the beans and rice restaurant
yeah Dave going to Bosley for hair I
don't know what that means it must be a
place you get hair for your head is it
like I had I mean it's like Oh implants
oh good yeah that's not gonna happen
either I'm way past that you would have
to care to do that and I don't care so
um that's a part of the problem Chris
Hogan singing tenor in a quartet only if
he had a helium balloon right you see
the routine he did with Rachel they on
the Rachael Cruz show they both have a
second on the helium balloons the Chris
and that voice coming out of Chris
Hogan's body just didn't fit it was just
completely wrong things that are more
likely to happen then Dave REMS using a
credit card